Behind The Fountains in the park lies a
city in Ruins
the feeling of normality here Fades
gradually as a drive around unveils
what's left of manipul
Alexandra's misery started with the war
and her ordeal has never ended up
just wish those people who are in charge
of all this would hear a mother's pain
it's impossible to live I just want to
embrace my only son alive and well
her son had to leave while she stayed in
Mario Paul to take care of her aging
mother
we did not believe it was possible to
survive we starved for a month without
water in the basement we saw people die
we didn't go anywhere after that
Arena and Lilia the childhood was
scarred with things that no one should
see especially when they are so young
now when a plane flies over I
immediately remember I am scared that
something will blow up I have started to
live one day at a time I used to put
things off but now I do them all at once
there may be no tomorrow
foreign
things have gotten much worse all my
friends have left we have to look for
new ones
just by looking at the ravaged buildings
the effects of the war can clearly be
seen and also felt across all facets of
life here in mariopol and its people
where the emotional scars of the trauma
they endured
Elena survived World War II in this same
city and during the Russian push she
lived in a bomb shelter
Russia is my native home I am glad now
because I received a Russian passport
I'm very glad that I will die in Russia
I am a Russian Ukraine did not give me
anything good we now sit and wait for
victory
what others in this city have a
different view they keep away from the
camera fearing the consequences of
associating themselves with Ukraine
their gaze is fixed on a distant Horizon
the hearts yearning for a future not yet
Within Reach
era Mario